Okay, welcome back to mental fitness, I think we have our voice portion or microphone portion
solved and we'll be feeding back those videos as we need.
So welcome back to mental fitness, we're here to talk about stress today.
So when I say that word, does it make you like tighten up?
Does it make you feel like stress is a bad thing?
When I talk about stress, do you get motivated?
Do you get inspired?
And what do you think of when I say the word stress?
So for today's exercise, I actually want you to write it down.
I want you to write down what you think of or what your beliefs are about stress.
So it could be any number of those things, write down, be a little bit specific, but
just take a few moments to do that.
Okay, so now that you've written down what you think of when I say the word stress, you
are going to think of how is this serving me?
So how is my above belief serving me in my writing and my goals in writing?
So after you've taken a few minutes to do that, read it back to yourself.
And oftentimes we get this picture of what our beliefs are really doing for our writing
or our lives.
And you may have not known this before.
And maybe some of you might have predicted that this belief is either causing harm or
causing benefit to your writing and your goals.
So it's important to know.
So for example, if you have the belief that stress is tension and bad, it's likely making
your writing tense and bad because writing just like any activity has a certain stress
on it.
And the reality is or the truth is about stress is that we go through so many stresses in
the day and we do great.
When you eat, it's actually a stress on your body.
But how does it feel?
It feels fantastic most of the time, feels healthy, feels nourishing.
And in the end, it is overall necessary and good for you to eat.
But it is technically a stress on your body, because the food goes in and the body has
to solve the problem of digesting it.
And that's pretty much the definition of stress.
So we're going to work backwards in the next point.
And we're going to say, what do you want to see in your writing?
What do you want as a result in your writing in the area of stress?
So write that down.
So this could be, you know, I want to feel prepared.
I want to feel strong.
I want to feel capable.
I want to feel loose.
And here it is, you write that down, just a few things, like three to five things, write
it down.
Then after you've written that down, like I said, we're going to work backwards.
We're going to see what belief would you have to have about stress in order to accomplish
that goal.
So for example, if you want to be loose in the saddle, you want to be relaxed and not
tense, your belief about stress has to be that stress is good for you.
There's a process in it and that you can let go and be relaxed in it.
So as you've written this out, what you've previously believed in, what it was serving
you for, and then what you want out of it really, or the service that you want and what
belief you have to have to get there, all of a sudden we have a mindset change available
to you.
So you have the opportunity now to believe one and get one result or believe the other
and get another result.
And just like anything, we can decide now to be better with stress or to be truthful
with stress because stress is not the killer.
It's not a bad thing and it's not something that we shouldn't or can't go through.
It's just a process of life that produces really good things.
And the reason why we call this mental fitness is because it's just like fitness.
When you work a muscle, you need to push against resistance in order to build muscle and to
increase strength, increase elasticity.
You need to do things, you need to make actions, you need to be in mindset for your body, not
against your body, in order to produce better health and better fitness.
And it's actually the same mentally.
So essentially what we've done here, we've decided where you're at and where you want
to go with this particular avenue of stress in writing, and you can choose to make a decision
to go forward with something more valuable to your goal.
But in order to keep doing that, we need to have small practical practices to optimize
and systematically go about training our muscles in our mind.
So there's a few things that you can do to do that.
And I like to call them micro stresses or purposeful stresses.
So you're going to purposefully put yourself in an uncomfortable or a different position
similar to a stretch or a lifting maneuver mentally in order to produce something better
for your whole life.
So we're going to go through three examples of what you can do.
So number one, to deal with something physical about your body is you can do therapy on your
body in the way of a cold shower.
You can do exercise every day, which we're already is part of our program.
And you can do something for your body that you know that it needs.
So either that's nutrition, therapy on an old injury, those kinds of things.
If you commit to one of those things for your physical body, then you can change your mental
state about the particular stresses.
Most of the time when people don't go to physical therapy for something physical, it's because
they don't want to be uncomfortable with the pain.
But what it really does is it elongates the pain to be longer and bug them for a longer
time in their life.
And we do the same thing mentally.
So go after it, get after it, do something physical for your body for the sake of the
mental.
So that's cold showers, exercise every day, or a therapy for your body.
And that could even be something like stretching if you would if you prefer mentally to separate
stretching from exercise.
So that's that's a really easy, tangible starting point for you to go because it's so it's so
easy to measure on your on your physical person.
Number two, something social.
So for example, if you are talkative, you can choose once a week, you are going to spend
10 minutes listening to somebody very, very actively and intensively to stretch your ability
to deal with your strengths and weaknesses in your mind.
If you're less talkative, maybe you want to stretch your ability by being the one sharing
with another person.
So once a week, you can spend 10 minutes talking to a stranger, talking to your spouse, talking
to someone else, a friend, and interacting in a way that's going to stretch you mentally.
The point is to get out of your comfort zone, okay?
And then number three is to do something personally or individually with your body.
So that can be even the meditation we did two weeks ago before you get on and ride.
It could be something you do in the morning where you wake up and you set yourself up
for the day mentally, a state of mind that you want to put yourself in, those kinds of
things that are personal and individual, and it just involves you.
So those are some very, very broad examples of you putting micro stresses on yourself
to help work the mental muscle of your mind so they can serve you in your life and your
goals even better than it already is.
As always, for the sake of the horse.